or president biden mentioned there the
hundreds of western companies who've now
halted operations in russia following
the invasion of ukraine but there remain
some big american and european names
still operating in the country however
pressure to pull out is only growing
for the employees of this renault plant
near moscow the news came as a shock
this morning at the start of their shift
they learned the assembly lines are
grinding to a halt
a russian employee appears before the
press and explains in french the plant
is closed for an indefinite period all
car production has stopped
it's a 180 degree turn around on the
part of renault just a few days ago the
french car maker said it would continue
to produce in russia despite the
sanctions imposed
in the end the pressure from customers
and politicians was too great
just this wednesday ukrainian president
volodymyr zolensky spoke to the french
national assembly via video link and
appealed to their conscience
french companies must leave the russian
market renault osha leroy mellen and
others
they must cease to be sponsors of
russia's military machine sponsors of
the killing of children and women
sponsors of rape robbery and looting by
the russian army
all companies must remember once and for
all that values are worth more than
profit
yale university in the us has published
a hall of shame a list of companies that
continue to do unrestricted business in
russia
among them are the swiss bank credit
suisse deutsche telekom and chinese
computer manufacturer lenovo
some companies such as nestle and
astrazeneca are fighting back against
the accusations and defending remaining
in russia
they argue that they have a
responsibility to continue supplying the
russian people with essential food and
medicines
well i've been speaking to jeffrey
sonnenfeld he and his team at yale
school of management have been
maintaining a list of companies who've
either pulled out or remained in russia
i asked him if he'd been surprised by
the reaction of western firms to the
invasion of ukraine it's amazing how
enthusiastically they and rapidly they
responded
it was um across industry sectors and
surprised by who moved in what sequence
the choreography has been surprising to
have big oil and energy companies on the
frontiers
of social change is not the normal
pattern and to have the
controversial big tech companies engaged
so quickly they've been of course in a
spotlight of a good deal of of
controversial scrutiny scrutiny in
recent years and then to have the
professional service firms that would
usually
rather jump off a cliff than engage in
in public conflict to actually get
involved in controversy this early it
was quite remarkable
yeah and has the actual presence of this
list made a difference because it's been
really quite widely distributed and and
the ceos of these companies clearly know
that this list existed so
has the list been growing because the
list exists
it's interesting a catalytic effect or
maybe even a snowballing effect as you
mentioned i didn't we didn't anticipate
it like we got involved just because we
saw the initial dozen or so
of the industries that i mentioned
walked out and courageously took a moral
position
and a dramatic one to withdraw from
russia
and then
there were a lot of pretenders because
the companies that weren't there were
the consumer goods companies packaged
goods companies food companies apparel
fragrances companies that usually are on
a leading edge of social change miss the
moment
and
with that but then they started their
public relations
spin meisters of their various um
uh efforts to create smokestream that
was very troubling
so um
that um that was a problem
we thought we should maybe be an
authoritative source that we have no
we're objective we have no involvement
with any of these particular companies
that we could uh
describe who is really doing something
and who is not and in that process
we wound up creating a catalytic effect
of saluting the people who were the
first movers although we didn't
necessarily intend to giving confidence
to the next group that wanted to but was
looking around for for peer approval
pure affirmation and then the shaming of
the last group of those who who were
digging in their heels uh refusing to
make a change that that had a huge
impact yeah we're just actually seeing
some pictures of some of the firms that
are digging in as you've put it uh in
your list
they're staying in russia how are they
justifying doing that
well um
it's through some very unconvincing ways
some of the oil servicing companies are
talking about the importance of what
they're providing on humanitarian
grounds no that's that's fueling the the
war effort some of the uh drug companies
who have argued again a humanitarian
argument which is um it's just not true
we don't know what's happening in those
labs we don't know what kind of research
is being done the um the european and
uh and american companies that had uh
oversight and those company those drug
labs don't now
and we don't know how they could be
repurposed for any kind of nefarious you
know biowarfare or whatever
but it's um it's the idea that they're
supposedly doing these clinical trials
that well those clinical trials could be
relocated and in fact all but one or two
of them did relocate uh sadly
astrazeneca did not but their
competitors did
but they um would argue uh i think very
unconvincingly also some of them the
koch industries of the u.s
uh that they are a paternalistic
employer which they never had a
reputation for being such an employer of
choice anywhere else
that now when it comes to russia they
want to take care of their long-service
loyal employees and we hear that from sc
johnson a big consumer products firm
that makes air fresheners and floor wax
and things like that
that they
they're concerned about the well-being
of their employees if they're concerned
about the well-being of their employees
you'd recognize that the average russian
citizen is in great danger if we're on
the brink of world war iii this is a way
of making sure we're not delivering
bombs and bullets to these people but
trying to
use a the last recourse of peaceful
government change